so we've got a new pope his name is
Francis it took the College of Cardinals
what like 15 minutes before agreeing on
a new leader for the Catholic Church the
largest multinational conglomerate since
Howard Johnsons went into chapter 11
despite serious theological and fashion
conflicts that make the problems between
East Coast and West Coast rapper seem
almost trivial in comparison the
Cardinals were quickly blowing more
white smoke than a studio session
featuring snoop Wiz Khalifa than
kottonmouth kings compare that to the US
government which hasn't passed an actual
budget in years that's supposed to
change over the coming weeks as a new
budget season gets underway just in time
for spring the House Republicans budget
was written by p90x enthusiast paul ryan
of wisconsin he promised a budget as
lean as his turtle ishes 12 pack abs
grrrrrr but Ryan's plan actually grows
federal spending by a whopping forty-two
percent over the next decade the Senate
Democrats who hadn't written a budget in
four years delivered a plan that raises
a trillion dollars in taxes and spends
even more than Republicans want to
President Obama was supposed to submit
his spending plan weeks ago but he
missed the deadline because he gotten
too wrapped up in this year's Easter Egg
Roll planning he wanted to make sure the
violist for that event is a hundred
percent accurate he's already said he's
not going to sign on to any budget that
he thinks guts Medicare or social
security and doesn't restore funding for
coral government activities like White
House tours so we may go well into
another year without a budget which
wouldn't be the worst thing in the world
without a budget real federal spending
has been basically flat despite the best
efforts of everyone involved to jack it
up a billion Catholics may be grateful
that the College of Cardinals run
smoother than an altar boys cheek but in
the good old USA it turns out the
gridlock has worked pretty well to
restrain government spending indeed if
and when American taxpayer see the white
smoke signaling agreement rising over DC
we'll all breathe a little worse for
reason TV I'm Kennedy